Canlıların sınıflandırılması
başlığındayız arkadaşlar. Bugün temel
mantığı anlatacağım size ve sonrasında
soru çözeceğiz. Hafta sonuna doğru da
inşallah bakteriler ve arkelere başlamış
olacağız. Şimdi ben diyelim ki size bir
yazılı hazırladım ve size yazılıda şöyle
bir soru sordum. Dedim ki neden
sınıflandırma yaparız? Öğrencilerimden
beklediğim aslında çok temel çok basit
kavramlarla bana bunları açıklamaları.
Hocam burada paragraflar dolusu cümleler
var. Hayır böyle değil. Ben canlıları
sınıflandırma gayretini şundan dolayı
yaparım. Bir doğanın anlaşılmasını
kolaylaştırmak. Sağımıza solumuza
baktığımızda bu canlı kimdir, nedir, ne
yer, ne içer, neye bağlıdır, bunları
anlamlandırabiliyor muyuz? Buna bakarım.
Ya da düzenli bir sistem oluşturmayı
amaçlarım. Hangi canlı hangi grubun
altında kimi temsil ediyor? Kim atası
kim? Ya da ondan sonra gelen yavrular
kim şeklinde bir silsile hazırlamış
olurum. Canlıları adlandırarak ortak bir
dil oluştururum. X ve Y ülkesinde aynı
canlı keşfedildiği zaman kendi
kafalarına göre isim vermelerinin önüne
geçmiş olurum. Ne dedim az önce? Doğayı
anlayarak canlıların anlaşılmasını
kolaylaştırmayı hedeflerim. Geçmişte
yaşamış olan ancak nesli tükenmiş canlı
ile günümüzdeki türleri kıyaslarım.
Bunlarda değişim var mı? Gelişim var mı?
Akrabalık derecesine göre canlılar
arasındaki adaptif farklar neler?
Bunlarla ilgilenirim ve tabii ki
biyolojik çeşitliliğin anlaşılmasını
kolaylaştırırım. Ekolojik, ekonomik
kaynaklarını dünyanın tespit etmiş
olurum. İşte benim sizden beklediğim
temel cümleler bunlar olurdu arkadaşlar.
Öyle kendinizi hırpalayıp paragraflar
dolusu ezber yapmanıza gerek yok. Sadece
mantığımızı kullanarak biz canlıları
neden sınıflandırmak isteriz sorusunu bu
şekilde cevaplayabilirsiniz. Şimdi
biyolojik sınıflandırma sistemi
karşımıza tabii ki bir sürü kavramla
çıkar ama yeni müfredatta sadece bir
tanesini bilmeniz lazım. Biz şu anda
filogenetik sınıflandırma ya da doğal
sınıflandırma olarak adlandırılan
sınıflandırmayı kullanıyoruz. Yani biz
canlıları bilimsel olarak
sınıflandırıyoruz. Neye bakarak? Fosil
kayıtlarına bakarak, genetik
benzerliğine bakarak, embriyonik
gelişimlerine bakarak, vücut
simetrisine, anatomisine, fizyolojisine,
genetik yapısına, biyokimyasına,
enzimlerine mesela ribozomun yapısındaki
ribozomal RNA'ya bakarak sınıflandırma
yapıyoruz.
Bu bakteri ve arkelerin ayrımındaki en
önemli cümledir arkadaşlar. Birazdan
tekrar edeceğim. Demek ki bilimsel
sınıflandırmada
işte canlının dış görünüşüne bakıp, "Aa,
bu kuşmuş ya da işte bu memeliymiş
demiyoruz arkadaşlar." Ya da bir canlı
sadece suda yaşadığı için ona balık
demiyoruz. Mesela balina var suda
yaşıyor. Penguenin de bir kısım hayatı
ki avlanması suda. Ama öte yandan
gerçekten balık olan canlılara
bakıyoruz. Onlar da suda. Birilerinin
bunları ayırması lazım. Balina memeli
ama penguen kuş.
Mesela ifadelere takılmayın,
isimlendirmelere takılmayın. Deniz atı
diyor. Deniz atı at mı? Deniz atı bir
kemikli balık ya da balina köpek balığı
diye bir canlı var. Şimdi balina mı
köpek balığı mı? Dolayısıyla baktığınız
zaman bu arada köpek balığı o. Şimdi o
zaman sadece isimlere bakarak işte biz
ya da yaşadığı yere bakarak ya da dış
görünüşüne bakarak sınıflandırma
yapmıyoruz arkadaşlar. Biz özellikle
köken sınıflandırması yapıyoruz.
moleküler düzeyde sınıflandırma
yapıyoruz. Aksi iddia edilmediği sürece
bir canlının dışına bakarak sadece
görünüşünden sınıflandırma yapılmaz.
Günümüzde sınıflandırmada en önemli şey
tabii ki akrabalık ilişkileri
arkadaşlar. Canlıların arasındaki
akrabalık ilişkileri dikkate alınarak
yapılıyor sınıflandırma ve bunu yaparken
tanımlandırıyoruz canlıyı. Sonra
sınıflandırıyoruz sonra da
adlandırıyoruz. Bunun kim olduğunu
söylüyoruz. Latince birtım kurallara
uyarak. Taksonomi canlıları bu şekilde
sınıflandırmak için kullanılan bilim
dalıdır dedim ve burayı geçtim. Şimdi
bilim insanları tabii birtım takson
dediğimiz ifadeler, domain dediğimiz ya
da işte alt kategori dediğimiz birtım
kavramlar ortaya atmışlar. Günümüzde
sınıflandırmada kullanılan temelde ü
tane domain var. Bakterya, arkea ve
ökarya. Buraya baktığımız zaman bu üç
dominin altında da 6 tane alem var.
bakteriler, arkeler, protista, bitki,
mantar ve hayvanlar alemi şeklinde.
Tabii bu alemler işte şube, sınıf,
takım, aile, cins, tür şeklinde birtım
basamaklara ayrılır. Herhangi bir
kategorinin altındaki kategorilerin
sayısı ile ilgili bir sınırlama da
yoktur. Yani bir cinsin altında işte
yüzlerce tür bulunabilir. Sen şunu
diyemezsin. İşte bir cinsin altında
sadece 10 tür olacak diyemezsin.
Sınıflandırmada kullanılan basamak ya da
kategoriler takson olarak adlandırılır
arkadaşlar. Özellikle testlerde ve tabii
ki belki de yazılığınızda şöyle bir
soruyla karşılaşabilirsiniz. İşte
domainden türe doğru ne azalır ne artar
ya da türden domaine doğru. Düzgün
okuyun o yüzden soruyu. Bakın her bir
basamaktaki birey sayısı alemden türe
doğru azalır. Yani mesela alemler
diyorsun bir sürü alem var ama türe
bakıyorsun mesela homo sapiens.
Dolayısıyla burada birey sayısı azaldı.
Her bir basamaktaki bireylerin ortak
olarak sahip olduğu özellikleri ne
yapacak? Artacak. Nereye doğru? Türe
doğru. Tekrar söylüyorum. Alemler mesela
hayvanlar alemi dedim. Bir sürü hayvan
var ama indin aşağı homo sapiens insan
tek bir o basamaktaki ortak özellik
tabii ki artar. Dolayısıyla alemden türe
doğru ortak özellik artacak. Gen
benzerliği artacak. Protein benzerliği
artacak ama birey sayısı arkadaşlar
tabii ki azalacak diyeceksiniz ve soruyu
çözeceksiniz. Az önce ne dedim? Bir türü
tanımlar, sınıflandırır ve adlandırırız.
Peki adlandırmayı nasıl yapıyoruz? Bir
kural var arkadaşlar. Bu kuralda temelde
şöyle yapılır. Latince ifadedir.
İalik yazılır. İlk kelime büyük harfle
başlar ve ilk kelime cins adıdır. Dikkat
edin. İlk kelime cins adıdır. İkincisi
tamamlayıcı, tanımlayıcı attır. İkisi
birden tür adıdır. Yani sakın bu
cinstir, bu türdür falan şeklinde bir
kıyaslama yapmayın. Genelde de o şekilde
düşürüyorlar. Bakın. Orix gazella. Cins
adı kimdir? Orixer büyük harfle
yazılmış. Tanımlayıcı tamamlayıcı ad.
Gazella küçük harfle yazılmış italik
yazılmış. İkisi birden tür adı olmuş.
Yani ben dünyanın herhangi bir yerinde
orix gazella dediğimde öbür tarafındaki
bir bilim insanı kimden bahsettiğimi bu
şekilde bakın anlayabilecek. İşte biz
sınıflandırmayı bu yüzden yapıyorduk.
Sınıflandırmada temel birim türdür
arkadaşlar. Tür kavramı temel birim
olarak kabul ediliyor ve türe genelde
şöyle bir ifadeyle tanımlıyorlar. Genel
kabul gören yaklaşım. Bakın bu aynı tür
olduğunu kabul etmek için iki canlının
çiftleştiğinde verimli döl vermesi
gerekiyor. Tabii niye hocam temel dedin?
Niye herkes için böyle bir şey yok? E
bakterilerde eşeyli üreme yok. Arkelerde
eşeyli üreme yok. Onlar döllenmiyorlar
ama onların da aynı türleri var değil
mi? Dolayısıyla bu genel kabule göre
birisi size tür tanımını yap dediğinde
ortak atadan gelen çiftleştiğinde
verimli döl verebilen canlılardır
dersiniz ve olayı bitirirsiniz. Yalnızca
kendi aralarında verimli gen alışverişi
yapan bireylerin oluşturduğu canlı grubu
şeklinde bir genel ifademiz var.
Gördüğünüz gibi farklı farklı cümlelerle
aslında aynı yere ulaşıyoruz. Carlinne
ve John Ray arkadaşlar bu iki ismi çok
duyarsınız. İşte ikili adlandırma
yönteminde aslında Karlin'nin temel
kurallarının geçtiğini biliyoruz. O
zaman orayı tekrar et biz hocam. Birinci
kelime cins adı, ikinci kelime
tamamlayıcı ad. İkisi birden tür adı
olacak. Ve en çok karşılaşacağınız
sorulardan bir tanesi 4 yıl boyunca test
çözdükçe karşınıza bunlar çıkacak
arkadaşlar. Mesela diyecekler ki
kromozom sayısı ile alakalı konuşalım.
Kromozom sayısı türe özgü müdür? Hayır
değildir. Yani biz bilimsel
sınıflandırma yaparken bir canlının
kromozom sayısına bakıyor muyuz? Hayır
hocam burada kromozom sayısı
yazmamışsın. Neden bakmıyoruz? Çünkü
bakın dikkat edin. Mesela bir eğrelti
otu türünde 1320 tane kromozom var. Ama
Homo sapiens dediğiniz insanda 46
kromozom var. Eğer ben canlının
gelişmişliğini kromozom sayısına
bağlamış olsaydım A6 ounun benden daha
gelişmiş olduğunu ifade etmiş olurdum.
Ya da bakın dikkat edin burada kurt
bağrı bitkisi 46 kromozomlu ama insan da
46 kromozomlu fakat bunlar aynı tür
değil. O zaman birisi size canlının
gelişmişliği ile ilgili bir araştırma
yaparken bilimsel sınıflandırmada
kromozom sayısı dikkate alınır mı derse
hayır diyeceksiniz hocam. Kromozom
sayısıyla bir canlının gelişmişliği ile
ilgili bilgi alamazsınız. Moli balığı,
kurtbağ bitkisi, homo sapiens bakın
sabli antilobu insanlar gibi 46
kromozomludur. Ve bir de bakın şu
maddeyi ben çok seviyorum. Şimdi biz
türlere baktığımız zaman türlerin
bireylerinin kromozom sayısının sağlıklı
bireylerde aynı olmasını bekleriz. Ancak
bu da kesinlik
türün bütün bireyleri kesinlikle aynı
sayıda kromozom taşır ifadesi hatalıdır
arkadaşlar. Neden? İleride ben size
arıları, arıların çoğalmasını
öğreteceğim ve orada partenogenez diye
bir kelime olacak. Mesela partenogenez
bir kraliçe arının oluşturduğu
yumurtanın döllenmeden erkek arıya
olacak. Dolayısıyla n kromozomlu
bir hücre mitoz geçirerek n kromozomlu
bir canlıyı meydana getirecek. Ama
kraliçe arı ve işçi arı döllenme
sonucunda oluşacak. Yani dolayısıyla
baktığınız zaman arkadaşlar mesela
türlerin birçok özellik bakımından
birbirine benzediğini göreceğiz. Çoğu
türün sağlıklı tüm bireylerinde kromozom
sayısı aynıdır diyeceğiz. Bakın bütün
türlerde değil çoğu türün. Neden? Çünkü
mesela erkek balıları 16, dişiler 32
kromozomlu ama sonuçta bunların hepsi
sağlıklı bireyler. Dolayısıyla
istisnalar olduğunu unutmayacaksınız.
Kesinlik sorularına dikkat edeceksiniz.
Yine aynı şekilde birçok türde bireyler
aynı şekilde beslenir deriz. Mesela işte
takım ne yediğini söyler deriz.
Etçiller, otçular, hepçiler vesaire.
Ancak yine istisnalar var. Aynı türün
bireyleri arasında farklı beslenme
şekillerine rastlanabilir. Ha bu şu
demek değil hocam. İşte insanlarda
vejeteryenler var. Bir de et yiyenler
var. Böyle değil arkadaşlar. Hani o bir
tercih. Fakat buraya bakın. Dişi sivri
sinekler kanla beslenirken erkek sivri
sinekler bitki özleriyle beslenir. Bu
onların doğalarında var olan bir şey.
Doğal bir şey bu. Mesela anofel cinsi
dişi sivri sinekte sıtma mikrobu
bulaşacak ama erkeğiyle böyle bir
hastalık taşınmayacak. Yine vücut
büyüklüğü değişken olabilir. Aynı türe
ait bireylerde birinin dişisine
bakacaksın metreler boyunca ama aynı
türün erkeğine bakacaksın. Birkaç
santim, birkaç milim vesaire. Şurada
hemen sorusuna bakalım. Bakın burada bir
Güney Afrika çayırlarında yaşayan
antilop ismi verilmiş. Bu isim üzerinden
gideceğiz. Bakın hemen hemen hiç su
içmeyen, kurak ortamlarda yaşamaya iyi
uyum sağlamış bir antilop bu. Burada
bilimsel adı var. Bilimsel adının ne
olduğu, size neyi çağrıştırdı, nasıl
okundu? Bunlar çok önemli değil
arkadaşlar. Bilimsel adın nasıl meydana
getirildiğini bilmemiz lazım. Birinci
kelime cins, ikinci kelime tamamlayıcı.
İkisi birden tür adı olacak. Bakın
Nezotragus cinsinde sınıflandırılıyor.
Tür adı Moskatus değil, Nezotragus
Moskatus olacak. Bilimsel adına
bakılarak sınıflandırıldığı taksonlar
belirlenemez. Niye belirlenemesin? Bak
cinsi. Cinsinin üzerindeki işte ne
diyoruz? Tür, cins, aile, familya,
takım, sınıf, şube, alem. Eğer sen
buraya kadar gelmişsen bunların hepsini
bilirsin. Bak bunun hayvanlar alemi
olduğunu biliyorsun mesela şu anda. Peki
bu takımda mı? Hayır hocam bu tür
adıdır. Bu takımı değildir.
Sınıflandırıldığı aile bu değil. Bu cins
hocam bu da özellik dedin ya da
tanımlayıcı tamamlayıcı kelime dedin.
Dikkat edeceğiz arkadaşlar. Mesela ben
size işte iki tane canlı var. İkisinin
de sınıfı aynıysa şubesi alemi mi
aynıdır yoksa takım işte aile cins türü
mü kesinlikle aynıdır dediğimde siz şunu
söyleyeceksiniz. Hocam genelden özele
doğru gidiyorum.
Zaten sınıfı belliyse şubesi alemi kesin
ortaktır. Takım, aile, cins, tür
oladabilir, olmaya daabilir. O yüzden
ben türe kadar gelmişim. Türse cinsim de
bellidir, ailem de bellidir. Takım,
sınıf, şubem, alemim de bellidir. Özeli
verdim. Genel taraflar kesin ortak.
Aşağısı daha da özeli ortak olabilir,
olmay daabilir. 3 domain dedik.
Bakterya, arkea, ökarya, bakteriler,
arkeler, ökaryotlara bakıyorum.
Protista, bitki, mantar ve hayvan
şeklinde arkadaşlar temelde
gruplandırılıyor. Bitirmek üzereyiz
burayı. Biraz daha sabırlı olmanızı
istiyorum. Bakın canlılar başlangıçta
bitki hayvan olarak iki gruba
ayrılmışlar. Burada bir gelişim, bir
sistematik tarihe bakıyoruz. Sonra
mikroskop keşfedilmiş. Yeni türler
keşfedilmiş. Ondan sonra o keşfedilen
türlerin bitki ya da hayvan olmadığı
anlaşılmış. İşte protista diye bir alem
önerilmiş. Hücresel yapılar anlaşılınca
prokaryot, ökaryot ayrımı yapılmış.
Sonra bakteriler ve arkeler aynı alem
içerisinde incelenirken bir anda bir RNA
analizi yapılmış ve arkeler
bakterilerden ayrılmış. Demek ki bu çok
güzel bir ÖSYM sorusu olabilir aslında.
Bakteriler ve arkelerin birbirinden
ayrılmasını sağlayan en temel şey
aslında ribozomal RNA farklılıklarıdır
arkadaşlar. Bundan sonra üç domin
oluşturulmuş. bakteriler, arkeler ve
ökaryotlar. Sonrasında da arkadaşlar
işte alt gruplar meydana gelmiş. Bakın
bakteriler arkeler prokaryot hücre
yapısına sahip. Diğerlerine bakıyorsunuz
ökaryot. Ama hocam bakteri ve arkeler
prokaryot olmalarına rağmen neden
birlikte incelenmiyorlar? 1. Hücre
duvarında içerdikleri protein
karbonhidrat gruplarının farklılığı. 2.
ribozomal RNA dizilerinin farklılığı
arkadaşlar. Bu da bir kladogram olarak
adlandırılan grafik. Arkadaşlar bir tane
daha soru çözelim hemen. Bakın günümüze
kadar gelen araştırmalara bakmışlar.
Önce bitki ve hayvan olarak ayırmışlar.
Sonra monera, protist, mantar, bitki,
hayvan olmuş. Sonra da monera diye bir
şey olmaz. Bakteri ve arkeleri
birbirinden ayıralım demişler. Ve en
sona üç domainli sisteme karar
vermişler. Ne yapılabilir? Mikroskobik
canlıların keşfedilmesinden sonra yeni
kategoriler oluşturulmuş. Doğru. Bakteri
ve arkeler farklı dominlerde
sınıflandırılıyor. Doğru. Günümüz çünkü
bilimsel çalışmasına bakacağız. Bakteri
ve arkeler bir dönem aynı kategori
altında sınıflandırılmış ama bunların
aynı olmadığı anlaşılınca birbirlerinden
ayrılmışlar. Arkadaşlar yine burada çok
kıymetli bir tablo var. Zaman içerisinde
bunların hepsini tek tek göreceğiz,
tekrar edeceğiz. Zaten daha bakteri ve
arkelere girmedim arkadaşlar. Bunu bir
sonraki günde yapacağız. Bakın zarlı
organel çekirdek ifadeleri.
Arke ve bakterilerde yok. Ökaryotlarda
var. Ribozom tipleri 70Se, ökaryotlarda
80s. Ribozomun yapısındaki moleküllerin
farklılığı bakteri ve arkeyi ayırıyor.
Hücre duvarında peptidoglikan
bakterilerde var. Arkelerde yok.
Arkelerde farklı bir kimyasal madde,
farklı bir yapı var. ya da işte
antibiyotiklere duyarlı ribozom mesela
bakın dikkat edin arkadaşlar arkeler
genellikle bazı antibiyotiklerden
etkilenmezler. Bütün antibiyotikler
demiyoruz yine özellikle kloren fenikol
streptomisin gibi antibiyotikler ama
burada spesifik isim bilmenize gerek
yok. Metanojen metan gazı ile ilişkili
olan yer arke bu çıkmış sınav sorusuydu.
DNA'daki histon proteini çok kıymetlidir
her zaman. Yani DNA'nın etrafında
özelleşmiş ve adı histon proteini olan
proteinler. Bakterilerde yok. Arkelerin
bazılarında var. Ökaryotlarda olması
bekleniyor. Halkasal DNA vurgusunu yine
çok yapacağız. Kimde? Prokaryotlarda
var. Çünkü ökaryotlardaki lineer
doğrusal DNA diyeceğiz. Ve son bir soru
çözüp araya çıkalım. Bakteriler, arkeler
ve ökaryotlar çeşitli özellikler
bakımından karşılaştırılmış. Hangisi
doğru? Bakterilerde kromozom bulunmaz
ifadesi hatalı. N kromozomludur
bakteriler. Arkelerin ribozomları hem
protein sentezini hem de protein
yıkımını gerçekleştirir. Yıkım değil
sentez yapar ribozomlar. Ökaryotlarda
belirli görevleri yapmak üzere
özelleşmiş zarlı yapılar bulunur. Doğru.
Prokaryotlarda yok. Bakterilerin
çekirdeği bulunmaz. Ancak arkelerde
küçük çekirdek var. Hayır ikisinde de
yok. Arkelerde histom proteinleriyle
çevrelenmiş DNA'ya rastlanmaz. Hayır,
rastlanır. Ökaryotlarda da rastlanır.
Ökaryotlarda ve arkelerin bazılarında
histon proteini var arkadaşlar dedim ve
burayı bitirdim. Burada size örnek
birkaç tane canlı nasıl isimlendirilmiş
onları verdim. Şimdi bir mola daha
sonrasında güzel güzel soru çözelim.
Yeah.